e agora eu estava velho então podem
começar a perguntas aí né
lavar a cabeça da galera vou responder
o áudio da um pouco unimar e acerto e
beijo pra minha mãe dona da dívida para
natal o aperto produto não ele não teme
perder pra natal
minerva minha época por mingo galé da
paraíba aberto para a paraíba
antes mesmo de beleza vem aqui agora
vamos ver vamos ver vamos ver
pergunta de minerva para minerva oitavo
goto oi também pra morar na rua mesmo
ele não invadiu a mãe terezinha passear
vai travando muito net ruim um beijo pra
mim um beijo pra mim ela silva
aí vem o j
daniel galvão foi pro daniel galvão
vamos lá gravando muito
não beijo que pune agu pede gerbrand
global beats
é isso aí né ai ai direto pra mim alguma
amiga bárbara na rua mesmo
eu fui pra casa da minha namorada em
varginha largou a quitinete na metade
ainda moro numa quitinete estoque maior
agora mudei de hoje
a verdade é mandar um beijo pra mim é
clara vasconcelos um beijo pra 1896 até
domingo a mostra leva pra você vai
acordar e eu mostro para vocês é bom
sabe qual é a boa de hoje para
bem-vindos muito mais cedo a partir daí
com isso você na verdade não tão sexual
normal aqui então vamos lá gente graças
na capela naturalizar anos é quem
pergunta sem perguntas em que
apresentava coisa pode perguntar
esse é o momento de perguntar fazer
pergunta pra lá vamos lá
para e meu abraço no braço em rio eu
oi tudo bem também no fim para o marido
porque tu não vê o festival só pra em
recife eu não vou pro festival só pra e
aí e se o que não me chamaram o triste
ver mais aqui
perguntas perguntas perguntas nem
pergunta vou tentar dissipar a toda hora
mesmo
o microfone está um pouco ruim é quando
vem a fortaleza de novo não sei
provavelmente final do ano não sei
porquê mas todo mundo pergunta por
encontrar um lugar eu falo que o
condenado não levar são paulo não sei eu
já fui em são paulo mas só ficou no
aeroporto i e ii para picos piauí
com certeza o jailson ferreira lima
entre o pântano você tem
eu tenho e 18 anos e vou fazer 19 no
próximo ano o início tenho 20 anos o
bebê aela mona um início tão 20 anos o
bebê como passar uma namorada quando um
beijo pra mim cara da onu amado difícil
na verdade arrumar um namorado é fato de
ficar com ele por muito tempo uma pessoa
legal que você vai ganhar uma pessoa
qualquer pessoa qualquer parte do
planeta então acho que você também vai é
alguém que entrar ao vivo comigo tem que
entrar ao vivo comigo é falar no
facebook e manda o google+ é lógico é
que te pego google+ e dental vivo aqui
comigo no meu facebook e manda e fala
comigo eu passo link e você entra kielb
facebook tiveram no google+ usos e lanús
econômico sectur
vamos lá vamos lá quando entra joão
pessoa joão pessoa é o ds coutinho o
everton dias manga longa teresina ao
debater e zina é ricardo zonta vai
implantar a minha cachorrinha gente à
minha cachorrinha domingo ea mera
passado domingo e eu não quero acordar
ela é o intelecto que ela não vai querer
dormir hoje
então vamos respeitar ela foi é uma
aposta vai contar daqui a pouco ele vai
vir aqui e aí eu mostro pra você está
louca teresina do vinícius é vamos ver
mais gente é podem estar lá e que está a
aplicar em gostei aqui na a tecan bom
gostei embaixo tem gostei gostei e e é
isso aí vem para são paulo quando não
sei ainda fazendo frio nunca nunca nunca
venha morar em recife
queria muito estar lá para na rachada
uma nota da pata rachada você perde aqui
do paraná áfrica terra nativa ea dá um
beijo pra rayane painel leiziane
fernandes
o início está apaixonada por um cara da
bahia e eu sou apaixonado pela minha de
varginha 1.800 km e eu já fui lá já
beijei vai lá na barreira
é já passou já pensou em fazer um vídeo
por meio da portaria sim com certeza
eu gosto muito deles eu amo te amo cara
libera da bjl pergunta aqui o iml é uma
gostosa com a avó é um aprendiz oni ser
um tema próximo vídeo é um tempo muito
bom
é muito fácil você precisa fazer para
acessar a fan zone é você mostra pra mim
que você é muito melhor do que estar a
playboy tem tela e por aí
ela era quem quiser entrar ao vivo
comigo aqui é bom é só falar comigo no
chat do facebook
se você tiver google+ viu o google+ não
vai dar certo é deixou ver mais aqui em
rio de janeiro xuxa flp mary bode dos 20
muito obrigado agora essa miséria e o
risca a nossa senhora o é como eu falei
mas um vídeo com a família o kers e eu
queria muito mais aqui toda vez que eu
vejo ela eu vejo ela é é pouco tempo
ocupado para poder fazer um e nunca vai
apagar o vídeo é uma tática do vih com
ela
se você souber de janeiro a janeiro
cantar e acho que só vai se combina não
sei quem é essa música não não conheço
amy não conheço
ei ei galera é esse aí né
manda um abraço pra nayana abraçar a
carreira na a9 crel teve dinheiro do
piauí com certeza vai treinar eu só vim
pra cá ele vai fazer o índice
quando você vem e sip no fim do ano eu
falei no fim do ano
agora você tem de se aguentar o amigo a
bruna pinheiro windson oi é o último
namoro no último namoro ruim lançaria
não sabe por quê
por isso um pouco ruim mas o namoro
enfim foi ótimo não na aldeia
então vamos lá ver e mais alguma
pergunta você tem lembrado que isso não
vai durar uma hora e pouco tá aí será de
legião não pode comer demais
é eu num sei não sei cantar essa música
mamãe gothel verdade miguel dos reis
está com obras que me perguntei se eu
gosto da banda direto não não gosto de
olhar direto
não é que eu não goste tipo não escuta
de um beijo
michelle england ele
vamos ver vamos ver vamos ver vamos ver
pediram para eu cantar a música sem nome
da moça sem nome e sem violão e até
fazer uma limpa vai te amo eu gosto
tanto em você acha tanto do seu beijo
dar a sua enfim o amor só eu quem tem e
por isso eu quero você só pra num que
gosta quando eu pego na sua senhora
talvez isso te faça se sentir segura
não se preocupe minha pequena não tá vou
te solta
você é tão linda caminhando com roubo
aqui
melhor ainda é saber que você é só minha
e sorrisos e eu fui eu quem coloquei lá
o que me sinto por você fica não é
normal é bem mais que citam a morte que
ele arranja no carnaval é bem mais
namorar há por que alguém curte alterar
o status do seu relacionamento no
facebook
eu amo te quero é ver que não estava pra
mim tá garibaldi em santa catarina que a
ficha um time pra mim futebol é quem
gosta de teatro
eu gosto de lutas legais no espelho
animais pra parecer legal aquino e lá eu
gosto de gente legal só é legal é muito
bom
mando um beijo pra mim cada instante um
beijo pra você
agora a história é então vamos fazer
aqui
isso eu acho que outra pessoa apresentar
que ao vivo comigo né
vamos ver vamos ver vamos ver
o alan pereira tá pedindo aqui pra cá
ele chorou em sua mente sadia df nem tá
pra mandar um abraço pessoal tá bombando
pela bombando admitisse é vamos dizer
que travou o haiti e fala de roberto
moreira dá um salto aí pra de itabela na
bahia nos salvar e da dupla o cd mais
amo você ia tv em maceió terá ótimo a
pena moura filho muito para lá mas não
divulga o meu canal está pedindo ao pb e
nós tal tipo 1
gente por favor vá lá no planalto pb no
hospital de lá prefere ficar namorar aí
de pele
não existe essa de preferir e tal
preferir namorado
primeiro porque é o seguinte existe
momento da vida da sua vida que você
necessita e ficar e existe momento da
sua vida que você tem que ir lá também
porque porque senão mas que não vai e
vem inteira só então minha vida inteira
no ramo
então há momentos que é bom ficar é o
momento de abandonar eu no momento longe
para ter um namorado mas se fosse em
outro momento da minha vida talvez eu
preferisse está a minar a avaria
perguntou o que você gosta de fazer
olha eu gosto de tratamento
logicamente top
é eu sou uma pessoa normal como qualquer
um e eu não vivo só de gravar vídeo né
então o que é que eu faço eu o caso do
braille a gente bem pouco itep na
internet e monta o convite para gravar a
gente vai praticar banda rota eu gosto
também de uma arrumadinha lamentado não
gosto de ir para a bancada da frente é
conversar com um dos colegas ao jogar
baralho
eu gosto de jogar futsal também todo
sábado joga ali na quadra da jogatina no
bairro itaperu e é isso que eu gosto
o show de maria rita
é isso
atirei o pau no gato é não ter um vídeo
sobre isso e eu vou gravar acho que
amanhã esse vídeo
eu atirei o pau no gato e então vou
deixar pra com o hora de gravar
é você goste trt6 possam opinião em
relação a ele
logo está tudo bonito eu adoro ft
primeiro porque é como um país tão
importante pra outra pessoa
não é isso exatamente se você tem o ft
segue é isso que eu gosto então é muito
bom tê tê é sempre quem estava com
curuçá
muito obrigado a todo mundo cresce
sempre são paulo lugar que você mais
gosta de eu gosto dele na potycabana no
shopping
eu nunca vou pro shopping shopping olha
não vou pro shopping kinoplex do
shopping pra comprar fatias empate um
filme
oprah é é
o meio ambiente é uma coisa e na maioria
das vezes eu sempre dou uma passadinha
na frente na potycabana que é muito bom
muito família é tão pensando em me levar
não deve ter medo não me conhecer
a idéia é não porque me leva um pouco
assustada
tem muita gente ela tira minha rua aí eu
tenho medo mas acho que o leva para a
volta não é isso é top
quantas vezes você andava na rua sente
um perfume lembrou que alguém além de
muitas vezes é o seguinte eu tinha uma
namorada que ela usava sopre chu ele
perguntar prevejo que aconteceu eu desci
do ônibus e ela passou por mim e ele
perdeu a frente batendo na área de
lembrar logo bella e acho que só saber é
o que você achou linda muito linda muito
linda grande alento muito logicamente em
vai falar que gostaria muito mas eu
particularmente amei
não se esqueça de clicar aqui e gostei
também gostei é muito interessante
o adorava me amarrar e você clicando em
gostei
vamos ver mais e e perguntas perguntas é
o que você achou a holanda perguntando o
que eu achei um santana aí importa lá em
fortaleza
eu adorei essa galera muito boa gente
meio que estava com o carro oficial www
logicamente os fãs do game the new york
times disse que a gente um pouco a gente
mas enfim a galera ir a dona da empresa
para gritar alegre está muito bom adorei
é amanda agnelli fernandes wilson você
tem religião
não não tenho religião mas eu acredito
em deus que é graças a deus não acredita
em deus e eu fui evangelho por muito
tempo mas num oito anos me deu minha
parte é um pouco como foi sua primeira
vez
a primeira vez é para um pouco engraçado
acho que vou deixar pra um vídeo também
vai perder a graça
então vou ter aqui é o cara que é a cada
1.000 ele no começo é o diabo pra você
vencer o peixe também pra mim eo
fernando estão sendo bem tratado é o
homem aqui manda lo pra mão do são simão
em goiás um beijo assassinou
foi aí que já vem pra esse o meu carro
teve um dos maiores encontros de blog
é do ipea é também é regente para
defraudar di tá mandando a mesma coisa
no beijo que aparece como espanha tinha
não consegui ler
vamos ver aquilo
obter aqui vamos ver aqui as perguntas
da galé tenha seu telegrama nos fazem a
história da peça telegrama ano um selo
um salve pro inícios capa e gustavo
anjos foi a pergunta mais freqüente você
recebe a pergunta mais freqüente que eu
recebo é o electro youtube cunha é o
janete ribeiro é o cara você trabalha
com alguma coisa tem tempo de vir sim eu
faço um representante de uma marca na
camisa e eu também estava em um seriado
aqui três deles aliás chama e família
extra e família é essa e passa todas as
terças das 15 horas e meia na tv meio
norte
vamos ver o que mais leva não vai parar
tão cedo
eu vou e volto já
só pergunto quero
o time
o toma num dia em que a menina acordou
agora vou mostrar pra vocês pescávamos
passamos muito tempo você é chamado na
porta mais coisas mudem e o alho porró
[Música]
cuidado na então galera estava no carro
comigo e me apresentei
eu acho que ele tá aqui pra german
portela ea miguel lopes
[Música]
alguém tem alguma pergunta e eu eu creio
que quebrar a cabeça
01 8
e se alguém fizer uma pergunta chega
kkkkk
[Música]
um abraço está aberta tenho filho e
peter gabriel deve ter um encontro
depois verei o que vou fazer depois o
[Música]
seu exemplo como o tubo não é pro medina
assim eu venho em um clube
o ganho é começar e aí né
a cozinha é porque o meu computador fica
na tomada que era formada em cinema
assim é e sempre falei é mais algumas
até mais algum pego encontrei com uma
experiência de encontrar os outros
blogueiros do de outros estados
a camila o dodô é eu acho muito bom no
meu tipo um privilégio eu gostava muito
antes de fazer de tudo eu gostava muito
eles já né
aí você conhecer o contato com a câmera
muito louco pessoalmente é quem mais
quiser entrar é só mandar mensagem e no
bate papo aí eu vou tentar fazer sempre
aquilo né galera pra conversar um pouco
com a galera
o epp é da vontade do nosso parabéns que
você já deve ter muito bem o piauí é um
orgulho ter gostei por aí
obrigado até aqui no piauí teresina
e aqui em nossa opinião a doença volta
bem pra minha opinião respeito dos
anônimos e lá no planeta você tenha um
mês com um bico em manter mas como esse
lance de youtube paga por visualização
por acesso inscrito como uma [ __ ]
desfeito
acho que é uma ponta de ciência
aí que acontece pela propaganda diz que
sob o vídeo pela data do anúncio do
agora mude pois aí juntando tudo na
primeira causa de regras é pra isso não
é regra
músicas autorais uso de imagens também é
é particularmente é muito mais fácil
[Música]
usar uma trilha onde site que tem muito
grata por conta como começou tudo porque
eu particularmente só descobrir com um
piloto aprovado
eu fui fazer vídeos há muito tempo há um
tempo pra cá
[Música]
é eu também saí mundo acha que a técnica
é claro exemplo da gama fortalece novo
fortaleza não tenho que mandar links
como colocar na descrição do vídeo o
link fica melhor colocar o mesmo no
domingo aí pra arrancar tudo muita gente
aí vai travar uma noite boa noite adeus
à menina veneno e um mapa do site
o cara tem alguma pergunta pra fazer pra
gente sair do papel do papa com o brasil
da minha opinião sobre o papel do herói
o civic
eu não tenho eu não tenho religião mas a
fé em deus sabe
beleza é então eu respeito o papa como
líder religioso
acho que pra mim ele não é uma função
mais pé
eu sou uma pessoa tenho nenhuma outra
nada lá
aí o minério é é perfeito ele é eu
respeito ele como líder religioso
logicamente ele é um cara muito
importante para a igreja católica
nós os appel superfã gelli da umbanda
todo mundo quer uma pessoa normal uma
pessoa ou um líder religioso importante
assim como faz agora tá todo mundo
religioso e pastoral de ontem ele é um
livro de ouro é da católica que é o
caixão da igreja que a paraíba
então eu nem sei se é pecado só que eu
não acho que mais importante do que o
que tem e não achei mais importante para
que vem de dvd pirata
respeito ele é normal
a diferença se ele viesse eu não liberei
pennetta e 11 de outubro
esse vídeo com 1.6 da maior polêmica
velho to chegou a ver esse vídeo e fez
um vídeo falando que todo mundo só fala
de papa doc é maluco né
lá foi a piada nenhuma
só tem muita gente que não assistiu e
ópera lá pelo título aí foi começa a
falar lá está desinformada
eu achei
o que você acha desse dessa marcha das
[ __ ] é o seguinte o brasil é um país
democrático é ele quem estiver
assistindo a aaa ao vivo é curtir o som
a opel e dando retorno direto de nassau
isso é é quem estiver envolvido em tirar
um som a ele como está agora a tentar
então você mesmo é de que os vídeos da
berta 111 e ainda tem gente ainda pelo
retorno e não sou eu
o link está no youtube você tem que
clicar no click em 100 a 88 be italian a
gente conversa aqui para andar
então coloca o fone é melhor estiver
é tão bem como na sala para guaranésia
em minas gerais estava agora neve
roberto me dê atenção a você você
participou nas operações participam
ainda que devolver a parte dessa vez a
gente quer entrar aqui mas está o
google+ é mais alguma pedra se aquele é
você mesmo textos vídeos ao f5 é você
mesmo qual chama eu me perdi no vídeo e
o programa que eu nunca vi o pet é o pet
é muito o que cortar no olímpico mas
programa é são paulo só você baixa da
testament gratuitamente no baixaki tenta
procurar vídeo pé
corte o programa é esse aí já vai
mostrar de onde saiu isso basta não foi
só me foi a 96 colocando penal dele
curto novo software também ajudaria
também sei do meu trabalho de óculos num
retiro é mais dele ficou só voltou a
galera não tem um plano
assim o sonho mandar um abraço ao falar
isso alexandre agora que enfrentar a
crise mas não concluído
eu sei quanto tempo de ataque 50 minutos
até a placa é doar das 10 20 não me
interessa não me rendi onde vou sair
discurso atualiza e gravando aqui também
a bota
o pessoal ficou falando também de um
primeiro veículo ou não esperou nem
quando postou o voto aprovado tanto
sucesso
acho que ninguém espera não estava nada
mas estava preparado para tal mas aí no
youtube de baixo foi o nome do bar do
rock you tube
quem sabe eu acho que vou dar o meu
dever é gente o do invento na hora vai
entrar aqui com a gente na hora
lucas lira beleza irá entrar até agora
mas não era uma mulher tem alguns anos
eu já mandei onde link aqui mas nenhum
consegue conectar os inscritos instalar
os programas para poder dar um abraço
para camila moraes a pena de violão
violão passar o limp carl larry um beijo
para laura parente que está assistindo
aqui agora eu sei tudo faz um trecho da
música bate muito da tim é 13
eu vou está subindo forte no choro sim
na voz
não dá pra ver o melhor para estar de
novo lançado na mata é de qual música é
a da tim brasil
vou fazê-lo assim também mas eu sou o
que sou um cara que só come a menina e
lá é que ele só queria era que comer e
funil não ficará com e eu vou botar vai
ser aqui como ela sai e vai se salvar de
alan j estado que total subia não não só
falta a copa taquara de só falta gravar
que criou o colo de alguém um beijo pra
fernanda nascimento que está no titã bem
a equipe
o derek leinweber é verdadeiramente ela
silva de esquiva se aprofunda o time de
tirar mas eu tirei até quatro cadeiras
para a final
tive que baixar o app do do hangouts pá
que só com o google+ a vão também fazer
arrancar aqui um apelo pessoal pelo
tacuara operou pelo pc ou pelo celular
ou notebook
o governo deve manter um limite de 36
anos falou pra mim gabriel moraes é
alberto moura onde internet pode falar
em um retorno em fortaleza
aí talvez maranhão ano
ana luísa leal tudo junto conseguindo
isso com vocês
quem você entrega mais tal lucas entrou
lucas lucas apagado lei acabou de 70 e
agora a de que se tornando um marco no
negócio em si não mandou nenhum subir e
pega existe mais nenhuma mate papo
se juninho livre só o vídeo sem água
marrom foto
abel é a de luta unida mas não consegue
fazer aquilo que deve ter no caldo o
jantar em bate-papo do uol
já a cidade de idade
quem nunca vamos ver aqui tem uns
duzentos e vinte trinta pessoas durante
22 horas entrou no concílio ao invento
na hora entrou aqui e mudar de câmbio
aqui falei na hora voltando não e aí
ouvi não tá muito lentas aí não também
não foram poucas
falei aqui em fortaleza sobral sobral
vai conseguir continuar assim o diabo
agora pegou né
os ataque
galera que está aí e vamos lá no
facebook
beleza única de pegar um link no twitter
no meu triste agora de boa hora mandou o
link no bate papo o show live [ __ ] bom
né
além dos comentários aí o nome da
amizade e quase falta [ __ ] live [ __ ]
com eles
falta um passo à moda do esfarrapado
aqui respondendo às perguntas abaixo
como mudar e se andar daqui para mais 18
anos a responder à pergunta
a galera só perguntas homossexuais
polemizar e um pronto publicada a
responder às perguntas dos comentários
do twitter como é que funciona a
comentários
a beleza
então vamos lendo aqui na paz é uma
pergunta interessante pra você eu faço
também aparece aqui uma pergunta boa que
uns e pelo salário é o que chupam salada
pergunta o vinícius está perguntando por
que não criam uma intro o seu canal
meu nome é meu canal porque acho muito
todos corram cheguei só de crê
eu já comecei não mas é melhor manter
desse jeito que já é padrão já é a cara
do meu nome eu pensei que a vinheta da
uma da manhã dá um aspecto de tipo de
programa hotel é ligar a câmera e sair
gastando bem falando m a remete a
piu-piu a água é o couro come hbo que
ocupará a cadeira deve ter ficado com o
troféu tempo a moça paródia da música eu
achei foi bom
graças a deus eu bati um pouco de inveja
é claro que todo mundo né eu saiba não
pô gente quer falar a verdade que dá
aquela inveja disse que o porto começou
a educar é no caso eu comecei isso tudo
aí do nada faz você conhece pega 6
milhões de views perguntar quando foi lá
no esquenta
eu não assisti um programa na época eu
estava trabalhando na hora vem aí eu só
vi os pedaços no youtube depois é lá no
esquenta te perguntar o quanto de
visualizações pegou o vídeo porque
geralmente o programa de tv mente vai
pegou 6 milhões chega lá e fato pegou
500 mil
não é assim mesmo
tanto sucesso quanto à multa original
sem que a minha foi seis vezes mais
lenta data original pode ser mesclado
com amor no canta muito legal mas não é
móvel vacilar
hoje espero que gosta demais nem nunca
vai saber também que minha entrevista
foi meia hora passa dois mundos
a primeira hora entrevista passa aí você
de três minutos
é desse jeito mesmo eu edito meu filho
imagina a gente na casa
o problema da carioca também não fala em
1 30 minutos passando em vídeo feminino
ave maria
ela usa as perguntas a pergunta book o
brasília teve aí vai fazer uma parada
junto aqui vai ao old cavalo sexo é eu
voltar eu tenho agora e já foi 12
agora eu acho que no final do ano novo
na mesma cidade não estamos ao vivo para
a 325 pessoas
agora eu só tenho a natália na conta
d'água mim pô tá pedindo que você mandar
um beijo o fã-clube wigderson mania
mania
eu adoro a minha mãe adora ver que a
nossa tem pergunta tosca direita no
pânico negócio fortaleza e agora ele tem
um talento chichorro nem mais uma
pergunta no brasileiro e deixou procurar
aqui vai a minha fortaleza
volto já falou com a tua opinião e até
eu vou querer falar aí
qual sua opinião sobre cura gay
agora o pau vai quebrar não gosto aqui é
o agora
ai eu adoro e gay e não quero segurar a
man senhor não falar que é vou explicar
uma coisa que muitos muitos de vocês não
sabem a rocha o nome por gay entre ou
foi a globo é na verdade não existe
agora peguei e quem estiver pensando que
há um marco feliciano pio playmate neste
ano não criou foi o max neste ano é o
presidente da comissão e direitos
humanos
ninguém fai é só votar a favor ponta e
não é nem aquele que decide assim vai
ter ou não vai ter e ele só pode dar um
voto de uma pessoa normal
é tipo c presidentes e presidente você é
o é o presidente mas se os ministros
aprovaram na fórmula 1 não pode fazer
nada
ela não pode dizer sim eu sou o
presidente essa [ __ ] eu quero que tudo
estava explodindo não foge porque porque
ela é só é é um é como se fosse um carro
de um carro de som o cargo é só um nome
é ele quem criou é cid essa altura quem
é fã aonde joão bosco não sei que isso
aí é um pouco alguma coisa assim o nome
dele e e foi isso só e aí ele
simplesmente e opressão lá uma prancha
acolhe de jogo mesmo sem saber e ainda
tem gente que pensa que tem gente tô sic
que vai ser o que faz 11 estar aqui e
vou chegar na casa do gate toma por aí
não é o beijo gay e é não é um gay é
tipo não é a pessoa pensa que vai fazer
tipo nova ordem mundial que o exército
poderá entrar na casa de todos os games
metralha não fala de cura dele estarão s
é como esse tipo é tem gente que não
sabe mas saber que tem gente que é e
nunca aceitei
é o famoso game quadro não é isto ver
encubado é aquele que não é gay que quer
mas tem aquele que é e aí falam por
semana pode ser um homem tinha muita
vontade de voltar
só que ele é é aquele cara que já nasce
que já nasce gostando do do game ajuda
àqueles que ele pode fazer com que a
volta não é só o psicológico não é só
uma consulta um beijo de piripiri
pergunta 'que tal eles o portal o portal
uol o carnaval fora de época em natal
também pode mandar um beijo aqui né
como é que é assim é o chamado a água eo
rabo mandar um beijo para isabela
meléndez é não deixar a galera
meniconnect não é habitável e aí tabela
nem para mandar pra ver as perguntas
feitas a youtube é e custo sem ficar
atualizando também porque às vezes num
baixo documentário bbb talula
o boston em captura de iphone
a novacap e cachorro havia dose rocks a
mais perguntas a responder mais
perguntas polêmicas pegam as perguntas
polêmicas a partir de agora acabou a
gente fala com lá no youtube botar ouviu
falando do hotel enquanto o papo conta
cura gay também volta mas desde aí bomba
equivalente
agora estamos há um tempo para 360
pessoas no qual é a imagem é o que agora
vou ter que fazer uma coisa chata que eu
vou ter que tirar vocês é chamar o que
tá começando a pesar 1 a 1
eu vou deixar aqui o lucas lira tcheco
galera
um abraço e eu vocês tenham gostado aqui
e parte para a gente presa a falar uma
coisa do gênero portela uma coisa olha
eu vou deixar nada de tama curte o canal
esculhambou favor divulguem vai escolher
vou é quando a moça é persistir no canal
esculhambou melhorar a educação em sanna
que na parada então mais vou ter que
tirar a equipe do rapidão não vou lançar
uma loja agora
rolou abraço ainda jovem
pronto agora só o gostosão e lucas
o vale amor vai lá no youtube um vídeo
no youtube no japão
a soja brasileira tinha eu soba é o
windows on enquanto os anos sem perder a
virgindade
olha meu colega meia-noite a
correspondência
depois da meia noite
outro interesse paredes inês imea no
próximo mês
o fla deve mandar um jovem entrou assim
ocimar que está assistindo aqui o canal
sigam me os bons preços
assistindo a gente que esse capacete
olha o lucas me manda tomar no cu
o eduardo vai tomar no cu vez que é
apenas um problema que teve que não sei
que isso não vai ser a gravar um livro
amanhã vai lançar paródia né
amanhã faz quanto tempo que ela sempre
demonstrou toda sua linha de novo muito
mais e já gravou não não é isso não
posso gravar eu não posso gravar no dia
assim não porque eu gravar
aí eu não agüento
não exibiu vamos lá
quer dizer que o windows só vai
responder com quantos anos perdeu a
virgindade depois da meia noite né
é bom que segura a audiência né vamos
bombar a rede globo aqui agora é isso aí
depois da meia-noite menor de perguntas
colegas vamos ter mais do que tu tá só
está carregando a idéia pergunta que só
de grama aqui agora
a audiência subiu mais ainda é agora um
paulo esquentou mesmo talvez algumas
pessoas diferentes e 85 postar vou
postar um link na fanpage também porque
a companhia tem mais gente do que gente
que me segue
de novo na minha frente demorou então
agora eu só vou saber também não para
quem não é muito fã fez nessa boa agora
letícia também assistir ao youtube
práticas
obrigado a terra parou no entanto é
muito engraçado ao perguntar obrigado ao
vivo na contato com a água vai ter um
pessoal que eu vou postar um link que o
fórum que não conhece os comentários que
encantou pelo valoroso
aí quando sai do roth o ato vai desliga
o motor quebrado vocês cuidam do tema eu
vou revelar um segredo pra galera vai
ter um link maicon saiu com ele
o ep o direito a champagne button igual
a hora de ler ele escolhe uma lei ela
tava escolheu vamos fazer assim ó ó pá
da escola assistindo agora a regra agora
é assim vocês uma das perguntas
o enderson vai uma pergunta referente a
mim eu vou ler uma referente a ele pode
ser o índice embora vamos lá eu vou
fazer a primeira então em nota que deve
à noite o pau quebra
vamos lá
ora pampa é só mandar a mesma da demanda
daqui a pouco tá com apps sujo
hum
nossa bola eu acho que as perguntas
chegou muita coisa mas pergunta aumentar
a pensão é essa estamos mandando muito
bem é muito beijo vai achou interessa
aqui é pra mim não é a rocha loucas
gosta muito dessas vezes me manda um
beijo é a ana santos um beijo no santa
etelvina etapa disse que tem uma página
e 210.000 blog fala comigo aqui no
bate-papo negociar negociar aqui ó
aqui a pergunta pra tu não mais que eu
tenho muito besta não vou fazer do mesmo
jeito vai movimentar zé
o que você acha das pessoas que não
sabem o que é a muriçoca
a yoki também eu tenho eu quero que o
povo está tenho pressão alta é o filma
aqui também
às vezes eu falo muriçoca aí nego fica
achar o pano nos comentários o que fala
acho que estou falando errado é o
pernilongo pn longa meu ovo é clara
negócio marchan lá estão agora a não
acaba de fazer é da muriçoca bem os
anais de ensaia conversa com alguém
quando trabalhava não então isso aí é
isso é restrito até que nem eu nem aí é
restrito
é meio que o ócio criativo da gente está
assim na verdade
não isso aí não é lá não é comigo é
conversando sozinhas não vi conversando
com uma pessoa que eu acho que tá me
dando idéia dos gatos como é que é um
sonho que estamos a ver vai 401 pessoas
lá marcou e nós só tava em pergunta
polêmica que calma galera meia noite vai
mandar perguntas coleções espéria espere
é nossa ampla
qual é o nome da menina que tudo o que
aparece nas fotos do namorado não é a
minha namorada a bela e jovem
o nome dela é segredo mas que gostou da
aí eu respondi não gente
não vou dizer que nunca ninguém tinha
dela é necessário também namorado bem
também
eu não tinha nada
tive que aconteceu é ver pra gente ea
polêmica o lego uma - não é porque não
deu certo mesmo é lei
ele lança assim quando vai pra frente
o tempo que durou pouco bem durou que
três meses por aí
há pouco tempo eu vou fazer é sério oito
dias né
é é difícil no canto para ser muito
legal para ter os garotos para ter um
contrato
tudo do domingo
tento não haver ladeira empinada vai de
um cheiro aqui na minha boca o pessoal
ele carente qual banda vocês curtem of
eu acho que isso vai continuar a banda
só se for de fora né
gosto de kennedy rené de forma mais
formosas parada assim eu gosto de
headshot do vovô é o head like not do
dos tambores la roque do arrocha
vamos falar a verdade eu gosto de
oxigênio entrei bem e tem mais eu gosto
de 2003
eu gosto de estado na noite de banda
mandou em algumas músicas algumas
músicas de cada grupo né
é exatamente é nem sempre era o nome do
grupo só eu gosto e sei como é
sei como é quantos p da vida calma
pessoal
a hora para 68 é the tube agora não o
link nesta liberato pessoal não lucas
qual o nome do teu canal tem como
alterar o título da live onde israel
depois que o pai não sabe tentar também
colocava no total dele é ele promete
puxar lhe ter ido é é é só a produção do
gugu parafernalha e do porta dos fundos
fábio porchat estava lanchando ali na né
minha cozinha ou não mas a namorar agora
se quiser achar meus vídeos é só
escrever meu nome escreveu no canal não
escreve lucas lira na coisa simples 12 t
para quem é alfabetizado né
na luta e vamos pra próxima
vamos lá galera
embora a nossa pergunta sair todo eu tô
rosa maria quadra para encarar o vitória
nossa só pergunta homossexual vai mandar
um abraço
guilherme araújo james com um mês agora
que eu tentei que bota
eu e meu filho tá confesso a minha vida
da mãe corre o último do teclado no chão
na porrada lá também que o mercado teve
nada eu passei esse tempo até se pode
querer que vocês acham do justin bieber
vem pergunta [ __ ]
eu vou falar não na moral eu não eu não
acho nada porque eu nem conheço não
conheço uma música dele porque as um
vídeo dele é o mais visto do youtube e
ele ficou muito tempo na página inicial
acabei ouvindo que a baby né
sei lá o quê um bilhão de visualizações
perde só programa não está eu não
conheço é com esse trabalho dele e nem
quero também o hino só pergunta que dá
michel se você já sofreu alguns
preconceitos ser piauiense falar
sempre acontece e acontece sempre
também nem todo mundo sofre preconceito
pelo jeito de falar em dependência
grande herói e s funda né barriga ele
comentário só era visualização e
genético lá ele escolhia chama sotaque
nos comentários à lei é o espírito nesta
terça faz por dinheiro
ó
tem um blog é que meu endereço do canal
é o caio romano youtube é perguntando
como é que foi essa adaptação de mudança
de cidade
você morar sozinho uma pergunta boa
mesmo para morar sozinho tem suas eu já
mudei de casa três vezes depois que um
colega aí eu saí da minha casa tem que
passar por um colega da minha perna
aí eu fui pra um kitnet era muito
pequena eu mudei hoje pra cá
hoje mesmo o melhor e é um pouco maior
aqui tem mais tem janela e gravar pilar
era que lá não tinha janela tinha só 16
grava na porta de outra ordem negócio
aqui parecendo dentro aí essa daqui
também agora é bem maior
sabe é forrada a iacute é melhor com
gravata e segue para tocá lá está aí e
me dói fay
aí eu adorei
miley já mas não me adaptei bem é morar
só tenha defeito é a de respeitar o povo
só mais você também pode fazer o que
quer é e é bom ea ruína é mas eu gostei
da minha idade
depois do tratamento da água limpa
assalto por exemplo por exemplo é pra
comer como é que eu tenho fundão tem
cura e paz comigo
a beleza já tá bom então já sabe
cozinhar tranquilo
agora eu estou lá as casas eu fui morar
só mendigo mesmo porque só me hoje mesmo
me banana pra falar a verdade é o de
morar só é isso eu acho que quando você
decidir
aí ô ô ô ô 30 em 28 e um pouco ruim os
18 é nova
os 20 prefeitos ea pode querer escolher
pela bhp voltar melhor após uma pergunta
nessa noite de domingo velha caixa por
104 a gente
aleluia papai vamos ver se a gente for
interessante tivesse pênalti e até stand
up 1010 não podem andar a fila no
assalto quatro meco método dos usuários
alierta prata segundo a peta prata e 51
vocês ganham dinheiro com os vídeos do
youtube
isso já foi respondido mas vamos
responder novamente naquilo que diz que
acabou de chegar na parada vai sim a
gente ganha dinheiro com os vídeos e é
isso aí é é e não é pergunta me
encontrava a ser notada não estava nos
comentaram o hangout fica pesado
vou fazer prova vou responder às
perguntas que esquecer da proibição
responder junto que eu responderia
responde seguida é ter chance no sapato
responderam lucas porque você nunca
tirou o óculos nos vídeos
eu não tinha essa bosta é porque já é
parte da caracterização do personagem na
verdade é um personagem está aqui quando
eu boto óculos e um boné ea bandana é eu
representando ali na na frente da câmera
um uma parte da minha personalidade
16 aquela parte que era mais agressiva
que é mais que eu ache né
então você que é tipo eu vou dar um
exemplo clássico que vai vocês vão
entender o outro é como se fosse um
microfone que o silvio santos aqui no
pescoço aquela bosta mentira nunca cá é
caracterizar a ação vai já na educar
entendeu
é por isso que motiva vamos lá você né
para bichos anã nenê carro pelas
polêmicas faltam 15 minutos ainda passei
respondidas fala bem errado que o bêbado
né
é tanto seja que meu deus
a pergunta impõem verdade que você tinha
pago um tipo a em dois tipos da média
ele está fazendo a minha parte dos anos
eu tinha o cabelo 2 em desenho achou a
cabeça 3d o que eu sei que dei o meu e
eu já falei é preciso repetir de 10 em
porteirinha dia 10 vai te standard que
vai lançar o fato neto
o diário também na praça pedro segundo
ele tem a caixa tinha 4 de setembro
o mesmo se vai lá
monalisa fatura está pedindo a equipe ao
mandar um beijo para ela dizendo nós
temos mas a audiência do pânico na tv
então é isso ele tem o que mais tem mais
perguntas aí tem trocentas pergunta que
está sinalizado como spam que manda
muitas vezes e ficou lá qual é o la da
idéia o nome de vocês ganham quanto por
mês já têm a casa dele carro próprio
amor a são josé
tudo é claro uma mulher
sim não vou falar quem quer saber quanto
eu tiver o maior em média você ganhar
seu dinheiro legal onde o domínio assim
os 700 e 800 mil visualizações por mês e
é e e tipo penal tem que dar voz e dados
e tiver momento dado vai rever a sua
falta de fé e aí você vai tirar o pt
tenta evitar
você tira e terá seu centro a aicep e tá
pra quem não sabe para quem não sabe o
que é monetizar
que tem gente que não sabe né monetizar
um vídeo é quando você dá permissão para
o youtube para ele poder fazer
propagandas no seu vídeo ou seja você
vai liberar no youtube nos lançar
anúncios no seu vídeo então é preciso
anúncio que você recebe e tem também o
ganho por cliques também é que é pura
exibições a cada tantos exibições e
ganha tanto que eu não vou falar porque
senão me fundo né
mas é isso aí vai
é isso aí é só limpeza não é nada deu
presentes e doações
no mesmo dia ela e outubro também é mais
um vídeo da hora do canal é sempre lá
claro que irei sentar lá lá lá lá lá
lago não vim aqui pra lá conhece ele não
conhece a história de quem estão
inclusive a ta na hora eu sei quem é e
pediu que eu te conheço há muito tempo e
aí minha jovem ele não pode é verdade
não se não se inscrevam na minha no meu
canal porque eu sou muito desgraçado
eu só faço por dia mesmo que se [ __ ]
cara eu acho que a coisa chega eu tinha
que fazer que meteu o título na bagagem
sair daí eu acho que tem como vai ser
mas é que está assim no ar o tempo mexer
e não dá certo para eu me defendo uma
ajuda os paranavaí o pé na cabeça ele
que na enxada e ana
adianta ainda a enxada adianta nada o
que é do mesmo mas eu acho que não era
para eu ver se bloqueará o meu também já
esperava isso e aquilo
no outro dia eu já achei que já não está
mais lá mas a sorte porque eles avaliam
que deve ser avaliado como mo mas se
fosse um vídeo tão mal sabia eu quero
mamar na verdade ela não tá ferrada pega
na rua mas tomou posse como do título
mudou
mudei isso aí
se o título fosse o antigo certeza que
tinha tirado como é de uma cheira cola a
inundar a minha jovem com certeza eles
vão tirar eu tive que mudar em windows
ou trava ou se vamos responder às
perguntas enquanto isso tá fazendo sei o
que a gente pode mandar a pergunta
também pra cláudia youtube também tem
essa moça tá falando vai procurar em
canal aceitar a cláudia e confere a 50
lá cláudia tenta laclau que é isso aí
pra quem me pra quem está aqui por por
uma indicação que não conheceu cláudia o
canal do som lá cláudia e pra quem não
me conhecia o meu canal é o invento na
hora
estou fazendo uma propagandinha aqui
básica na época